I’D LIKE TO HEAR IN
YOUR WORDS JUST BRIEFLY
WHAT THIS MOVIE IS ABOUT
-THIS MOVIE IS ABOUT PARENTS
FINDING OUT THEIR KIDS ARE
MAKING WHAT THEY FEEL
IS A BAD DECISION AND
TRYING TO STOP THAT BAD DECISION.
RIGHT, BUT REALLY
THIS MOVIE I S ABOUT
BUTT CHUGGING.
OH, YES.
THERE’S ALSO THAT.
I’D LIKE TO KNOW
WHEN YOU WERE FILMING YOUR
PIVOTAL BUTT CHUGGING SCENE
DID YOU USE A STUNT BUTT
OR WAS THAT YOUR BUTT?
THERE IS NO WAY TO, TO
EQUAL THE PRESENCE OF MY BUTT.
SO, YOU DO YOUR
OWN BUTT STUNTS?
I HAVE TO.
IT WAS A MASSIVE CASTING PROCESS.
WE SENT OUT FOR THE
ASSES OF THE WORLD.
AND YOU COULDN’T FIND ONE?
IT WAS JUST NOT ANYTHING
THAT MEASURED UP TO THE
THE HAM-LIKE SUBSTANCE OF BUTT
MEAT THAT I CAN PUT ON SCREEN.
AND WHAT KIND OF PREPARATION
DID YOU PUT YOUR BUTT THROUGH?
THE TRAINING, THE PREPARATION,
THE MENTAL EXHAUSTION,
THE EMOTIONAL ROLLERCOASTER.
BUTT CHUGGING CAN,
CAN RUIN A RELATIONSHIP.
I MEAN, IT'S NOT FOR EVERYONE
AS A MATTER OF FACT, I
RECOMMEND THOSE AT HOME
THEY DON’T TRY IT.
I WOULD START WITH SMALLER
OBJECTS LIKE THE CAP OF A TIRE
THAT YOU PUT THE AIR IN,
MAYBE THE CAP OF A
TUBE OF TOOTHPASTE
WORK UP TO
NON-BREAKABLE MASON JARS
AND THEN INFLATABLE INNERTUBES
WAS MY LAST STEP.
CAN YOU RUN US THROUGH HOW
THE DIRECTOR PREPARED YOU TO –
KAY WAS GREAT.
ALL GOOD DIRECTORS LET
YOU OWN THAT WORK
AND SHE SPECIFICALLY SAID
“YOU KNOW I’VE
BROUGHT YOU THIS FAR
I’VE GIVEN YOU THE CLIFF NOTES,
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO
JUST OWN THE WORK.”
SO, I WAS AT GREAT LIBERTY TO
CHUG AS I SAW APPROPRIATE.
-AND REALLY FEEL OUT THE SCENE
YES
THE SCENE TAKES PLACE
AT A HIGH SCHOOL PARTY.
AND ON THE DAY, THERE
WERE 120 TO 150 EXTRAS
THAT HAD TO “STARE INTO THE
CHUG” AS WE DEEMED IT ON SET
AND I’D LIKE TO THINK
THAT I GAVE THEM THE
EXPERIENCE THAT
ANYTHING’S POSSIBLE
AND WHAT UH-
-I MEAN IF YOU LOOK AT THE PROS
AND YOU CAN SCOUR
YOUTUBE FOR THIS
EVERYBODY HAS THEIR
OWN TECHNIQUES
AND SOME ARE FILLED WITH
CONSISTENT LAUGHTER
I DON’T BELIEVE IN THAT BECAUSE
YOU CAN PUSH BACK OUT.
SURPRISE IS CERTAINLY AN ELEMENT
YOU DON’T WANT TO
BE INVOLVED WITH.
I THINK ITS MOSTLY A STATE,
A MEDITATIVE STATE
OF FINDING EMOTIONAL ONENESS
WHERE YOU DON’T,
YOU DON’T DEVIATE.
YOU GET A RESTING HEART RATE,
ALMOST LIKE, YOU KNOW
LONG DISTANCE RUNNERS
THEY KEEP A VERY LOW
RESTING HEART RATE.
ASS CHUGGERS IT’S THE SAME
AND YOU WOULDN’T
LOOK AT ME AND BE LIKE
THAT GUYS GOT A RESTING
HEART RATE OF 46
NO
-BUT I – I DO.
IS BUTT CHUGGING AN
ACTIVITY YOU DO AROUND
CLOSE FRIENDS OR YOU CAN
KINDA DO IN PUBLIC?
MY FAVORITE BUTT
CHUG OBVIOUSLY IS
CAPTURED ON FILM IN
BLOCKERS BECAUSE IT WAS
AROUND CLOSE FRIENDS,
IT WAS AROUND COWORKERS AND IT
WAS AROUND COMPLETE STRANGERS.
SO THAT IS, I BELIEVE WHEN YOU
REACH FULL CONFIDENCE
IN YOUR BUTT CHUGGING ABILITIES
AS AN ACTOR THE KIND OF MENTAL
TRAINING YOU WENT THROUGH –
I CHOSE THE STRAIGHT
FORWARD APPROACH
THIS THING IS GOING TO
GO IN MY A**HOLE
AND THEY’RE GOING
TO POUR FLUID INTO IT.
IT SEEMED TO WORK.
AND DID YOU HAVE ANY PRIOR
EXPERIENCE TO THIS BEFORE?
I – I- AT THIS POINT I CANNOT
CONFIRM NOR DENY THAT.
[MUSIC PLAYS]